après deux jours cloîtré dans son studio
de tahoua et winoto les maintenant prêt
à voir du pays
il a joué des coudes lui aussi sur le
terre je préfère les réunions
mais à peine arrivé à toronto le chef
conservateur s'enfonce dans un autre
hôtel pour une annonce qui il espère
incitera des électeurs à voter blanc
comme promet menace je vais offrir une
congé de la tps pendant tout le mois de
décembre
la mesure a beau être qualifié par
certains de populiste beau question pour
le chef de s'entourer de gens ou de
commerçants pour la détailler pourquoi
ce qui a pas un show ici pourquoi est-ce
que vous êtes tout seul c'est très
important d'avoir une approche
sécuritaire
une attaque à peine voilée contre son
adversaire libéral lui aussi en campagne
dans la grande région de toronto et qui
n'hésite pas à prendre des bonnes foules
malgré tout justin trudeau veut montrer
l'image d'un chef intransigeants sur les
questions sanitaires nous sommes sentis
fille qui veut que les fonctionnaires
vont devoir se faire vacciner pourtant
une note envoyée par une dirigeante de
la fonction publique indique que des
mesures de rechange comme des tests de
dépistage doivent être considérés pour
les employés non vaccinés ce que les
fonctionnaires aux causes et du trésor
ont dit était erroné et wind o'toole qui
s'opposent à la vaccination obligatoire
à que justin trudeau de cacher la vérité
on doit avoir plus de transparence et
c'est le temps de pour le 1er mai nous
de dire la vérité
ainsi que consomment les vaccins pour
les fonctionnaires des experts en santé
publique trouve dommage qu'on politise
le débat sur la vaccination obligatoire
et affirme que ça n'aide en rien les
efforts pour immuniser les canadiens
mais dans une élection estivale alors
que la quatrième vague émergent les
chefs tente de s'imposer avec des thèmes
qui touchent les canadiens et surtout
qui leur permettent de se distancier de
leurs adversaires et si laurence martin
radio canada avec mario